when you get this movie the one you're
promoting out southpaw which we also
unloved and you didn't know anything
about boxing really when you got into
this role right I mean you were not
you've never done martial arts as a kid
and you never right yeah so you decide
to do a boxing movie Kurt Sutter wrote
it that's the guy from Sons of Anarchy
yeah he's great right great great guy
and you wish it was my neighbor at one
point I remember I was hammering
something in my house and he was just
like I remember screaming what the [ __ ]
is that noise stop [ __ ] hammer and
also cool is that [ __ ]
right and it we met up at scooter yeah
but he's scary looking too he looks like
he could kill somebody for real right
and then like it is in the movie
business yeah two years later we're
making a movie of course yeah everyone's
your best friend yeah but you trained
like it was a real boxing match right
yeah
because if I put on weight I get a belly
and tits yeah now when you put on the
same you were doing ice stain so what is
the training for southpaw what do I have
to do to get in that kind of shape cuz
you're super ripped in it um I trained
for five months I trained twice a day
for five months right so I would I
basically I'd wake up in the morning and
over time I added miles to my roadwork
but I'd start at like three miles and
then eventually I was running eight
miles and then I would go and I'd work
out for two hours you do MIT work heavy
bags did you know how to do speaker box
your training oh yeah yeah did you know
how to do speed bags well I don't know
how to do anything because when you hit
that thing it's hot it actually is hard
to hit a speed bag and do it oh my like
I don't know how to jab I mean I I mean
I sucked right and then over five months
you know every single day twice a day
you just start learning the techniques I
mean took me two months to get speed bag
and like to feel confidence and did you
spar with people oh yeah oh wow yeah
yeah I think allowed to hit you in the
face so because I mean listen man you
got good looks you'd want to my face
nobody gives you [ __ ] yeah yeah oh you
got let's zoom I've been hitting face so
what is so when you're when you're in
that situation are they allowed to hit
your face you can't condone a move they
can hit my face it I did hit my face but
we body's barred for a majority of the
the practice training sessions right and
then we then we got into hell full-on
sparring and then six weeks out we sort
of we got we sparred a bit and
we just started focusing on choreography
could be the choreograph all these lines
you know it is amazingly how actors can
get their bodies to morph into you know
I mean it's a full commitment
yeah I mean actors it's just like to me
everybody asked me what you know why
would you not wanna get in the face
that's like you know that's most
important thing acting and I'm always
like most the most interesting thing to
me and acting is learning from people is
like learning what people are actually
doing in real jobs that matter right do
you know yeah and so if you get if you
get hit like that's that's part of the
job like and you can actually learn
something in fact there a number of
actors that should get hit yeah I
actually am one of them smacked around a
bit it was fine